final cut moi j'adore c'est pas ça le
souci et a quand même des trucs hyper
relou genre des problèmes qui reviennent
tout le temps qu'ils bouffent
complètement le cerveau alors qu'en fait
il ya des solutions
hyper simple et aujourd'hui on va voir
ça mais juste après l'intro
[Musique]
il salue les gens derrière l'écran c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique moi
encore je suis ravie comme à chaque fois
de vous retrouver sur cette chaîne cette
chaîne où on parle de création de vidéos
de montage de matos de caméras tout ça
tout ça donc si c'est quelque chose qui
vous intéresse et bien n'hésitez pas à
cliquer sur le petit bouton s'abonner
qui se situe juste en dessous la cloche
tout ça tout ça on a l'habitude
maintenant
alors vous le savez j'adore travailler
avec final cut j'adore mon logiciel mais
il ya des trucs qui prennent la tête
assez souvent et je le vois dans les dm
sur un stade vous me posez des questions
qui reviennent très souvent sur des
problèmes qui peuvent arriver et je me
suis dit que tout simplement j'allais
faire une espèce de petite compile en
fait des problèmes récurrents est relou
qui arrive sur final cut et surtout de
leurs solutions les solutions qu'on va
trouver à ces problèmes là et donc sans
plus attendre on va directement dans
final cut et on va tordre le cou à ces
problèmes qui reviennent et qui nous
bouffent le cerveau alors le premier
problème c'est les fichiers manquants
quand vous voyez cette icône de la mort
et que vos fichiers sont perdus
comment ça peut arriver c'est tout
simplement en fait que final cut ne
trouve plus les fichiers qui
correspondent à votre montage il ne sait
plus où ils se trouvent sur votre
ordinateur alors ça peut arriver assez
souvent quand on déplace une
bibliothèque et les fichiers qui vont
avec sur un disque externe par exemple
pour l'archivé puis on se dit tiens je
vais le ressortir jeu le brancher et là
paf icône de la mort le truc rouge
on est en flip on dira j'ai perdu tous
mes fichiers tout ça alors que pas du
tout en fait il suffit juste de les
relocaliser alors pouvez voir donc on a
notre fameux fichiers manquants notre
icône rouge et qu'on n'a plus rien dans
notre montage et on est en flip
on peut même voir ici qu'il ya un petit
point d'exclamation sur l'événement qui
montre qu' il manque des choses mais
c'est tout simple ne paniquez pas pour
résoudre ça on va sélectionner la
bibliothèque on va aller dans fichiers
on va aller dans relier les fichiers on
va ici demandez à tous localisés
on va aller sélectionner le dossier dans
lequel se trouvent ils tous nos fichiers
puisqu'on sait où ils sont vu qu'on les
a déplacés sur un disque externe par
exemple et choisir ensuite y molines y
retrouve tous on clique sur relier les
fichiers màj tous nos fichiers sont
revenus comme par miracle rien n'était
perdu le deuxième problème et ça
c'est un truc qu'on me demande tout le
temps c'est comment je peux faire pour
réduire la taille de la bibliothèque
parce que il faut savoir que final cut
fait du rendu en temps réel c'est à dire
qu'il est en permanence en train de
convertir vos fichiers pour en faire des
vidéos et non pas avoir à calculer à
chaque fois tout ce qui se passe sur la
timeline quand il ya de la colo quand ya
des effets etc et donc ça crée beaucoup
beaucoup de fichiers c'est pas étonnant
que sur une vidéo de 10 à 15 minutes on
se retrouve avec une bibliothèque qui
fait entre 100 et 200 giga ce qui est
énorme quand on bosse sur un disque
interne et parfois même quand on bosse
sur des disques externes pour vous
donner un exemple ici alors il n'y a pas
eu beaucoup de rendu de fait mais vous
allez voir déjà rien que ça on arrive à
quelque chose de plutôt intéressant j'ai
ma bibliothèque ici qui fait 50 gigas
pour en réduire la taille je vais aller
dans fichiers supprimer les fichiers de
bibliothèques généré est donc ici on a
supprimé les fichiers dans dû supprimer
le média optimisé supprimer le média
proxy à langer pas fait de proxy donc ça
va rien changer
par contre il a fait du rendu sur des
fichiers que je n'utilise pas ou plus
dans mon montage donc ça je veux le
dégager et même à la limite j'en veux
dire on pourrait tout dégager si on veut
archives et notre projet alors pour vous
montrer je vais faire comme si
j'arrivais je vais tout sélectionner
supprimer les fichiers de rendu tout le
média optimiser le proxy sait jamais
s'il en a fait sans que je lui demande
pourquoi pas et on va cliquer sur ok et
la magie on tombe sur 1,87 giga en est
passé de 50 à un peu moins de 2 gigas on
navire est tous les fichiers de rendu et
donc du coup on a vraiment soulagé la
mémoire ici pour archiver c'est parfait
donc pas d'inquiétude si vos
bibliothèques deviennent hyper grosse il
ya toujours moyen de les réduire une
fois le montage fini mais prévoyez quand
même un disque suffisamment importants
pour pouvoir monter de ensuite une
question qui revient souvent c'est des
problèmes avec les profils hlg alors je
vais vous montrer tout de suite si je
prends ici des fichiers en hlg que je
mets tout simplement directement dans ma
timeline sans avoir rien fait eh bien
regardez on se retrouve avec un fichier
totalement cramer c'est juste
dégueulasse
parce que le a changé ici utilise un
espace colorimétrique qui s'appelle le
rec 20 20 est que notre timeline elle
et en règle 709 tout simplement il ya un
problème de compatibilité alors je peux
aussi complètement montée en chêne géant
règles 20 mais là on va juste essayer de
faire ma che serait que 20 20 avec
d'autres plans qui sont en règle 709
pour ça je sélectionne mont blanc où je
sélectionne tous mes plans de mon
navigateur aussi je peux le faire je
vais aller dans le petit ici dans
l'inspecteur je vais bien vérifier que
je suis ici dans réglages si je ne le
suis pas je vais aller le chercher ici
et ensuite je vais tout simplement aller
sur remplacer la colorimétrie je vais
passer sur dur etc 709 si ma timeline
est un rec 709
màj ici la surexposition a complètement
disparu non votre plan n'était pas cramé
non vous n'étiez pas complètement
surexposé quand vous avez tourné un
autre problème que vous pouvez
rencontrer ces admettons que vous avez
commencé vous avez créé un projet en
full hd en 1080p finalement vous vous
dites que vous le voulez en 4k houle
inverse où est ce que je peux changer
ces fichus propriété du projet et bien
c'est tout simple on va aller
sélectionner notre projet on va aller
ici dans l'inspecteur et cliquez sur
modifier et ici s'ouvre la fenêtre qu'on
avait au départ pour créer les
propriétés du projet la seule chose
qu'on ne pourra pas changer ça va être
le nombre d'image par seconde mais tout
le reste on peut le changer on peut
renommer
on peut ici passer à de la 4k roux
repartir en full hd
on peut modifier les codecs de rendu etc
etc
donc c'est tout simple pour passer sur
ça pas besoin de créer de nouveaux
projets ensuite un point qui est pas
très compliqué mais qui parfois peut
être un peu relou c'est si par exemple
j'ai une musique dans mon montage et
qu'à un moment donné quelqu'un parle et
que je veux baisser la musique à cet
endroit là alors je peux toujours mettre
des qui freinent une de pour le début
pour baisser un petit peu le volume mais
il ya une solution beaucoup plus
pratique je vous montre ça tout de suite
alors ici donc je suis en train de
parler mais ma musique elle est beaucoup
trop forte et je voudrais admettons
baissé juste ce passage-là ici où il ya
du pétrole
eh bien je vais utiliser le raccourci de
la touche r pour l'outil de sélection
je vais sélectionner tout simplement la
zone sur laquelle je veux baissé
le volume de la musique je vais baisser
le volume de la musique et vous remarqué
que mais qui frame se sont mises
automatiquement et que j'ai un petit
fond du que je peux régler plus ou moins
intenses en fonction de ce que je veux
du résultat que je veux et c'est pas
plus compliqué que ça ça va très vite et
ça va vous simplifier la vie
6e problème qui peut se présenter à vous
c'est la timeline magnétique
on aime ou on aime pas moi j'adore mais
il ya des fois j'avoue j'aimerais bien
l'an passé j'ai envie de bouger un petit
peu mais plan comme j'ai envie j'ai pas
envie qui se collent entre eux et ça
c'est quelque chose que normalement on
peut pas faire sur final cut
sauf que il ya une petite astuce alors
c'est de la bidouille mais ça marche
très bien
c'est d'utiliser un fonds qui va nous
permettre de casser cette timeline
magnétique je pars sur un nouveau projet
et je vais utiliser la touche option
w pour créer un fond noir ici je vais
les tirer sur la longueur du clip que je
veux utiliser et ensuite je n'ai plus
qu'à sélectionner mes plans et je
pourrais les places est absolument où je
veux sur ma timeline indépendamment du
magnétisme sait rien à faire et c'est
hyper pratique quand vous avez besoin de
supprimer ce magnétisme qui peut parfois
vous pénaliser la 7e astuces elle va
vous plaire si vous voulez synchronisée
de l'image et du son par exemple là je
suis en train d'enregistrer le son
séparément de l'image après au montage
il va falloir que je les regroupe tous
les deux eh bien peut très bien le faire
manuellement en regardant les formes
d'onde avec un petit clapot début
essayer de caler sa à la main mais des
fois c'est pas toujours hyper précis il
ya une commande pour ça qui est très
très très très simple qui va vous éviter
de perdre un temps monstrueux à le faire
à la main vous allez voir je vais
sélectionner ici mon plan face caméra
ensuite ici j'ai ma voix donc je vais
faire un command clic pour sélectionner
ces deux là sans prendre celui du milieu
je vais faire un clic droit sur mes deux
plans synchroniser les plans et un
raccourci aussi ses options commandes g
je veux lui donner un nom face cam
synchronisée on va le laisser moulinet
un tout petit peu et j'ai donc mon plan
ici avec la petite icône de la
synchronisation qui va aller là alors je
peux double cliquer dessus pour aller
couper le
de base parce que sinon je vais avoir
les deux et moi je veux garder vraiment
celui du micro et une fois que ça c'est
fait c'est terminé tout est synchronisé
à la perfection c'est un outil magique
alors il ya un autre truc qui peut aussi
être un peu relou du fait des
connecteurs qu'on a dans final cut on a
les plans qui vont venir s'accrocher les
uns aux autres on a aussi par exemple le
son qui va venir s'accrocher à un plan
en particulier et par exemple ici si je
veux bouger ce plan là un peu plus loin
et ben j'ai la musique qui vient avec et
ça ça me va pas du tout moi je voudrais
que la musique elle reste au début pour
ça je vais cliquez sur mon plan dont je
veux bouger le connecteur qui est ici
envoyé que la musique est déconnecté à
ce plan là je vais mettre ma tête de
lecture ici et je veux tout simplement
faire commandes option clic et hop
pouvez voir que mon connecteur est venu
se fixer ici exactement exactement à
l'endroit où je voulais qu'il se
connecte alors on est presque à la fin
l'avant-dernière vous allez bien aimé je
pense l'idée c'est ici par exemple j'ai
fait mon montage et ce plan ne me
convient pas j'aimerais bien le
remplacer par un autre alors je pourrais
aller en prendre un autre l'a juste
essayé de faire en sorte que ça colle le
mettre à la place mais il ya beaucoup
plus simple que ça je vais aller tout
simplement ici sélectionnés on va dire
que je veux remplacer ce plan-là par
celui là je vais aller sélectionné mon
plan je vais lui mettre un point
d'entrée avec ea je m'assure que il est
suffisamment long pour combler ici tout
l'espace je vais sélectionner le plan
que je veux remplacer et je vais appuyer
tout simplement sur option r et boum il
est allé me chercher le plan du dessus
pour me le mettre à la place voilà j'ai
même pas eu besoin de modifier la durée
il me lemay tout pile aux dimensions du
plan précédent il le remplace et c'est
juste parfait
enfin la dernière astuce et moi c'est
une que je trouve vraiment vraiment très
très cool cet asus elle va consister à
modifier la vitesse d'un plan sans en
modifier la durée parce que ici
typiquement si je prends ce plan là et
que je veux finalement je veux plus du
slow mots je veux un plan à vitesse
réelle
donc je vais appuyer sur la touche
commandes r pour afficher ici la vitesse
et je vais lui mettre normal
et donc forcément j'ai mis normal donc
du coup mon plan est rétrécie ce qui est
normal puisque bien il ya moins d'image
par seconde on est passé du ralenti à la
vitesse ray et moi j'aurais bien aimé
garder la durée parce que ça me fait
tout mon montage au final si j'ai calé
tout sur la musique etc
il ya un truc pour ça je vais
double-cliquez sur la durée ici je vais
aller dans personnalisé et je vais
vérifier que ondulations n'est pas
cochée à partir du moment où on dut la
scion n'est pas coché je vais mettre ma
vitesse à 100%
màj je me retrouve avec un plan à
vitesse réelle mais qui fait exactement
la même durée que mon plan au ralenti
donc mon montage n'est pas complètement
pété ce pratique tout ça quand même
d'ailleurs si vous avez trouvé ça hyper
pratique et d'un n'hésitez pas à mettre
le traditionnel coup deux blaster sur le
pouce en l'air qui situe juste en
dessous de cette vidéo allez voir il ya
plein de vidéos sur finale que je vous
donne plein d'astuces ya ma formation
aussi sur haut débit si jamais ça vous
intéresse d'aller plus loin et de
découvrir les bases et d'être un boss de
final cut
- les amis en attendant je vous dis
rester curieux et à très bientôt pour
une prochaine vidéo